stop
science bonjour et bienvenue pour ce
stop science aujourd'hui consacré à
cette question existentielle et
fondamentale du genre humain la mère de
toutes les questions c'est qui qui est
venu en premier l'œuf ou la poule j'ai
bien envie de vous répondre la réponse
classique que c'est une presque poule
qui a pondu un œuf contenant une vraie
poule ou bien même de dire que l'œuf
amniotique est apparu bien avant que les
poules n'apparaissent bah oui des les
dinosaures en pondaient déjà et les
premiers vertébrés en pondaient aussi
dans ces deux cas la réponse est
indiscutablement l'œuf mais en réalité
tout cela dépend de ce qu'on appelle un
œuf et une poule bah une poule une poule
c'est une poule et un œuf c'est un œuf
ben un œuf comment je sais pas moi un
œuf de poule ENF un œuf un œuf quoi donc
qui de la poule ou de l'œuf de poule est
venu le premier je crois que tu as ta
réponse seulle une poule peut produire
un œuf qu'on peut raisonnablement
qualifier d'œuf de poule d'où cette
question c'est quoi une poule ma fa mes
cheveux non parce que les poules c'est
quand même une fabuleuse diversité de
formes et de gènees qui saurait dire
dans toute cette diversité où commence
la définition de la poule et où elle
s'arrête car si pour toi une poule c'est
ça alors celle-ci n'en est peut-être pas
une et dans ce cas-là ça veut dire
qu'une poule ancestrale normale a un
jour pendu un œuf de non poule et alors
là la question est complètement
retournée peut-on terminer sur un œuf
qui vient en dernier poulet poulet
dire qu'un animal est une poule c'est
dire que la notion de poule préexisteré
à l'existance de l'animal c'est une
définition fixiste anti-évolutionniste
de la poule ce n'est qu'une
catégorisation de notre esprit la nature
elle n'est pas faite de catégorie les
poules d'aujourd'hui sont très
différentes de ce qu'elles étaient il y
a 6000 ans pourtant nous n'avons jamais
cessé de les appeler des poules une
poule est une poule qu nous choisissons
d'en faire une poule on donne au mot
poule une définition avec un
commencement et une fin à la notion de
poule mais le terme poule est infini
tant qu'il y aura des gênnes de ces
galinacés pour se reproduire la lignée
des poules ne cessera jamais d'être la
ligné des poules toute cette apologie de
la volaille n'est là que pour vous dire
que la réponse à la question l'œuf ou la
poule ne dépend que de la définition
qu'on s'accorde à donner à l'espèce
poule voilà c'est tout donc vous l'aurez
compris aujourd'hui on déchaîne les
passions avec le sujet le plus central
de toute la biologie l'éternellement
irrésolue question de la classification
son des espèces les genres musicaux les
Pokémon les DVD les partis politiques ou
les espèces vivantes faire des petites
cases au sens propre comme au sens
figuré est indispensable à notre bonne
compréhension et appréhension du monde
mais attention ces petites cases ne sont
qu'une construction de notre esprit les
musicaux se savent bien on ne leur colle
pas d'étiquettes à eux quand on crée un
nouveau groupe on ne pense pas à la
catégorie dans laquelle les disquers
vont nous classer non non non on joue ce
qu'on aime et puis c'est tout la
classification ça vient après cet
accessoire ce n'est qu'un accessoire les
espèces vivantes c'est pareil tracer une
limite entre un monde végétal d'un côté
et un monde animal de l'autre est
purement arbitraire basé sur une
frontière que nous avons nous-même fixé
à savoir la capacité à changer le soleil
en énergie physiologique ce qu'on
appelle la photosynthèse évidemment il y
a plein de contreexemples à ces
catégories voici une salamandre et un
puceron des animaux capables de faire la
photosynthèse et voici le lquen une
étroite symbiose entre un champignon et
une algue et on le range où celui-là et
c'est sans compter le nombre de proystes
des êtres unicellulaires ni animaux ni
végétaux qui ont tous appris à faire la
photosynthèse indépendamment les petites
cases ont leurs limite et tracer une
démarcation nette entre le pool et le
non pool quoi que plus évident repose
sur le même mécanisme arbitraire la
classification n'est qu'un moyen de
simplifier notre représentation de ce
qui nous entoure retenir quatre ou cinq
catégories est beaucoup plus facile à
faire pour notre petit cerveau que
retenir chacune des 50 nuances d'un
interminable continuum de gris et le
vivant ce n'est que ça un long continuum
d'espèces qui ont évolué les unes à
partir des autres depuis 4 milliards et
demi
d'années quoi ça y est c'est parti les
gros chiffres les dates vertigineuses
les dimensions géolique qui donne le
tourn et la grandeur de l'univers et
l'infinité des possibles on peut pas
faire plus court plus court oui plus
court plus court plus
court ok alors faisons cours faisons fun
faisons ça rock and roll
[Musique]
c'est du rock ça non mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que cette vieillerie ça ça c'est
un bon vieux rock bien rétro
ouais non mais mais ça c'est pas du vrai
rock là il nous faut un vrai truc un
truc qui pulse tu vois dans le genre du
Metallica
quoi non mais c'est pas du rock ça c'est
du bruit arrête-moi ça tout de suite non
mais le vrai bon rock c'est les FIF
Elvis bib non mais n'importe quoi les
trucs de vieux tu vas voir si je suis
vieille non mais toute façon les enfants
je vous arrête le solul rock le vrai
c'est celui des Beatles voilà alors on
arrête de se battre et on se prosterne
devant les véritables stars du rock
Beatles non mais d'où il sort celui-là
et puis tu es qui toi moi c'est Sican je
bosse à côté sur la chaîne palé World ah
bon on peut savoir depuis quand tu es là
bah en fait ça fait bien 5 minutes et
maintenant vous allez arrêter de faire
tout ce bouquan et de vous chamailler
comme des chifonniers car les Beatles
mettront tout le monde d'accord le vrai
rock a le son 7ties plutôt crever le son
prends ça prends ça prends
[Musique]
ça nous avons tous déjà vécu une
situation similaire les classifications
sont arbitraires et les critères
arbitraires sont sujets au mieux à débat
et au pire à la baston chacun est sûr
d'avoir raison de connaître la vraie
classification parce qu'en réalité
personne n'a tort Elvis les Beatles
Metallica jouent tous du rock certes
différent mais suffisamment proche pour
que les catégorisés dans des petites
boîtes tournent rapidement en pugila
maintenant il faut vous imaginer qu'en
matière de classification animale et
végétale on ne parle pas d'une dizaine
ni d'une centaine ni même d'un millier
de catégories comme il peut en exister
en musique ou en littérature non on
parle de millions d'espèces et chaque
semaine on en découvre de nouvelles
trois primates parci une méduse par là
et des organismes unicellulaires comme
si il en pleuvait comment arriver à
ranger catégoriser et classer tout ce
monde là sans déclencher une guerre
civile la réponse est simple les
scientifiques se sont mis d'accord à
chaque fois qu'une nouvelle case une
petite boîte si vous préférez est créée
que ce soit une espèce un genre ou une
famille entière le premier représentant
de cette case qui a été découvert et
décrit servira de point de repère de
spécim caractéristiqu pour toutes les
fois suivante où on voudra ajouter un
autre représentant dans cette même boîte
dans le cas du rock par exemple je suis
désolé désolé de lui donner raison mais
c'est ma très chère camarade qui est
dans le vrai je sais je sais merci merci
le premier genre musical à avoir reçu
l'étiquette de rock and roll c'est bien
le rock des années 50 le bon vieux rock
rétro ce n'est qu'ensuite que de
nouvelles catégories de rock sont venu s
greffer notez que le bon vieux rock
rétro n'a pas disparu pour autant la
famille du rock s'est juste diversifié
et ramifiée et le rock des fifties a
évolué donc quand bien même vous
considérez que le style d'vis ne
correspond plus vraiment à ce qu'on
appelle du rock aujourd'hui c'est bien
son rock à lui qui doit servir de
référence pour tout ce qu'on appellera
du rock par la suite en tout cas du
point de vue scientifique comme ça tout
le monde est d'accord et oui car à la
star des êtres vivants le rock évolue et
c'est en agrégeant tous les styles
musicaux autour d'un spécimen de
référence qu'il devient possible de s'en
rendre pleinement compte de Elvis à
Metallica en passant par les Beatles le
punk
et ça le rock a beaucoup changé depuis
son apparition et la classification
permet de le souigner ça s'est passé
exactement de la même manière pour les
espèces vivantes bien des années avant
qu'une théorie de l'évolution n'émerge
en Europe alors qu'on croyait que les
espèces étaient complètement fixes le
naturaliste Carl van Liny proposa une
classification des animaux qui fit date
et pour cause elle rangeait l'homme et
les singes dans une même boîte une case
de première importance que Liné a de se
fait appeler les primates mieux encore
il considérait le chimpanzé comme un
représentant du genre Homo il faut dire
que les points communs sont nombreux on
trouve de pouces opposable et de doigts
dépourvus de griffe mais se finissant
sur des ongles que chez les primates
nulle part ailleurs Liné n'avait
rencontré pareille expressivité du
visage ni une telle complexité
comportementale et sociale pour sûr s'il
fallait mettre l'homme dans une petite
boîte c'était bien celle où se trouvait
déjà le chimpanzé et pourtant il faut le
redire Carl von Linet n'était pas
évolutionniste pour un S car la théorie
de l'évolution n'existait pas encore
l'idée que l'homme et le chimpanzé
partagent un ancêtre commun n'est venu
que bien après et même pas sous sous la
plume de Darwin non et encore moins dans
l'origine des espèces comme on l'entend
trop souvent Darwin s'est bel et bien
intéressé à la question mais bien après
hxley dans son ouvrage la place de
l'homme dans la nature hxley ajoute un
concept fondamentalement très simple à
l'idée de Liné pour Liné si deux espèces
se ressemble c'est qu'elles vont dans la
même boîte comme l'homme et le chimpanzé
mais pour hxley si deux espèces se
ressemblent c'est peut-être parce
qu'elle partagent un ancêtre en commun
comme des frères et sœurs se ressemblent
parce qu'ils descendent d'une même mère
c'est tout c'est aussi simple que ça
hugley n'avait pas besoin de fossil il
n'a pas lu l'évolution dans les archives
fossilisées il l'a deviné et ce à partir
des espèces actuelles comme on peut
deviner en découvrant un poussin et un
œuf cassé côte à côte qu'autrefois il ne
formait qu'un et c'est pour cela que
depuis Oxley la classification des
espèces sur laquelle les scientifiques
travaillent d'arrachepied depuis
l'époque de Liné et même bien avant lui
et sans cesse retravailler pour qu'elle
calque l'arbre de l'évolution du vivant
en effet si vous déclarez les dinosaures
ont disparu vous prenez un groupe les
dinosaures dont vous excluez
volontairement et sans raison apparente
certains représentants les oiseaux en
l'occurrence afin de pouvoir conclure
que les dinosaures ont disparu mais ce
n'est pas vrai les dinosaures n'ont pas
complètement disparu puisque les oiseaux
en font partie et que eux sont pour le
coup bien vivants ça mon petit pu bah
alors qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
façon de faire de la classification
mettez donc tous les descendants des
dinosaures dans la même famille
diriez-vous que votre famille s'est
éteinte simplement parce que votre AOL
est mort en 1418 évidemment que non
alors pourquoi le faire pour les
dinosaures et quand vous dites l'homme
descend du singe vous créez une
opposition entre l'homme d'un côté qui
ne représente qu'une espèce et les
singes de l'autre comme si tous les
singes représentaient un ensemble
cohérent et à part de l'homme mais c'est
simplement faux le chimpanzé a plus à
voir avec l'homme qu'il n'a à voir avec
le gorille donc le chimpanzé aussi
descend du singe non non en fait l'homme
descend du singe de la même façon que
tous les singes descendent du singe ça
n'a juste pas de sens de nous séparer
d'eux alors évidemment l'avantage du
rock and roll c'est que le premier
exemple de musique qu'on a appelé rock
est aussi le premier à être apparu et
est donc l'ancêtre de tous les autres
comme d'ailleurs on a aussi vu
apparaître tous les styles de rock les
uns après les autres et à partir des
autres on n' pas de mal à reconstruire
la généalogie et l'évolution du rock à
travers les années forcément avec les
espèces animales qui évoluent bien plus
lentement que les goûts musicaux ça
marche moins bien et c'est pas pour
autant qu'on a jamais vu de nouvelles
espèces apparaître de mémoire d'homme à
commencer par les chiens et les chats
domestiques et puis que ce soit cette
espèce de lézard isolé sur une île est
différente par sa morphologie de sa
population ancestrale des moustiques
dans le métro londonien différents géné
itiquement des moustiques de la surface
ou bien encore ces autres lézards tous
descendant d'une unique lignée de
femelles et possédant un nombre trop
élevé de chromosomes pour pouvoir un
jour se reproduire de nouveau avec leur
population ancestrale sans compter les
bactéries qui se reproduisent si vite
qu'on les voit littéralement évoluer à
l'œil nu ce ne sont pas les exemples qui
manquent mais c'est loin d'être la règle
voir une espèce évoluée ça reste
excessivement difficile donc quand vous
vous baladez dans la nature et que vous
trouvez une nouvelle espèce il y a peu
de Chan qu'il s'agisse précisément de
l'espèce S ral dont serait issu toutes
les autres espèces de la même famille
que vous trouverez ensuite non ça ce
serait quand même miraculeux faut pas
trop ponter quand on trouve une nouvelle
espèce animale puis qu'on y agrèche
toutes ses cousines ça ne vous
reconstruit pas comme ça tout de suite
la généalogie de cette famille même avec
un fossile dont on connaîtrait l'âge ce
n'est pas évident car un fossile récent
peut avoir une origine évolutive une
racine très ancienne l'homme de floress
par exemple a été contemporain de
l'homme moderne pourtant il n'est pas
notre plus proche cousin c'est pourquoi
au lieu de parler d'arbre généalogique
c'est c'est-à-dire d'un arbre
représentant les liens directs
d'ancêtres adescendant entre les parties
en présence comme c'est le cas avec le
rock on préfère parler de phillogénie
c'est-à-dire cette fois d'un arbre
représentant les relations de parenté
des liens de cousinage si vous préférez
prenons quelques espèces de poisson plat
voici la première espèce découverte la
sole puis le turbo deux espèces encore
vivantes et quelques espèces éteintes
comme amphystium découverte bien plus
tard classonsles maintenant par ordre de
ressemblance le degré de migration de
l'œil peut nous aider d'abord il y a un
œil de chaque côté puis un œil à moitié
migré chez cette espèce éteinte puis un
œil complètement migré sur l'autre côté
de la face chez laassle et le turbo
actuelle il faut faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable que les ressemblances qui
unissent ces espèces les unes aux autres
sont des innovations que la migration de
l'œil est une caractéristique unique qui
témoigne d'un lien de parenté dans ce
cas on fait l'hypothèse que ces
innovations sont apparues chez une
espèce ancestrale hypothétique un
ancêtre commun qui se serait vu être le
premier doté de ces innovations c'est
pourquoi l'ancêtre commun est dit
hypothétique ce n'est pas un véritable
ancêtre mais simplement une bifurcation
de l'arbre philogénétique où on pense
qu'une innovation est apparue si
d'aventure on découvr une nouvelle
espèce possédant ses innovations les
mêmes caractéristiques biologiques
typiques alors qu'ell soi actuelle ou
fossile cela voudra dire qu'elle descend
de ce même ancêtre hypothétique et donc
qu'elle appartient à la même famille et
par conséquent au même groupe cette
méthode de classification basée sur les
innovations évolutives uniquement est
appelée cladistique mais attention ça ne
marche qu'avec les ressemblances qui
sont des innovations si vous tentez de
classer l'ornitorin parmi les reptiles
parce qu'ils pont des œufs alors vous
vous tromperez car comme c'était déjà le
cas pour les poules les œufs sont bien
plus anciens que les ornitorin la réelle
innovation la signature que l'évolution
a laissé au fer rouge sur les ornitorin
et qui nous indique où les classer c'est
l'allaitement l'ornitorin allaite ses
petits ce qui est une caractéristique
unique des mammifères les êtres dotés de
Mamel hérité d'un lointinancêtre commun
que l'ornitorin partage avec bah avec
nous cet ancêtre commun que nous
partageons avec l'ornitorque
effectivement est un être hypothétique
dont on peut néanmoins dire à partir de
cet arbre philogénétique qu'il possédait
déjà la capacité d'allaitter ses petits
mais il faut aussi faire attention aux
sis et oui deux personnes qui se
ressemble ont de grandes chances d'être
de la même famille mais il existe une
probabilité certes faible mais non
négligeable qu'on ait affaire à des
susis cela peut-être dû à une adaptation
à un mode de vie similaire ou bien même
à du mimétisme par exemple une espè
espèce de papillon non toxique pourrait
ressembler à une autre espèce toxique
celle-là ce qui lui permettrait d'être
évité par les prédateurs sans avoir à se
soucier de produire du poison et oui en
matière de classification toutes les
caractéristiques ne se valent pas mon
petit monsieur la classification c'est
un métier auquel nous vous conseillons
de vous initier grâce à l'application
pour Smartphone cladistica en conclusion
classer les espèces c'est bien mais avec
des innovations évolutives c'est mieux
mais attention la classification n'est
pas une fin en soi classé oui mais
autant savoir pourquoi la classification
n'est qu'un outil pour apprendre à s'y
retrouver dans un musée ou dans un
herbier par exemple c'est aussi comme
nous l'avons vu une bonne façon de se
représenter l'évolution mais classer
juste pour classer ne sert à rien
d'autant que depuis Liné et même hxley
la définition du mot espèce a bien
changé j'ai même envie de dire qu'elle a
évolué et oui un biologiste ou un
généticien d'aujourd'hui vous dira que
ces unités qu'on appelle des espèces ne
sont ni constantes dans le temps la
faute à l'évolution ni même dans
l'espace les exemples sont légions de
populations d'organismes CAPA de se
croiser entre elles de proche en proche
mais dont les populations les plus
distantes ne sont pas interféconde
s'agitil d'espèces distinctes ou pas et
que pensz de néanderta les sapiens deux
humains anatomiquement différents et
pourtant interfécond des limites à la
notion d'espèces comme cela il y en a
plein donc classer les organismes oui à
condition que cela réponde à une
problématique prenons la médecine par
exemple la raison pour laquelle on teste
les médicaments sur les souris blanches
et pas sur des des cafar ou des plantes
vertes c'est bien parce que les souris
sont très proches de l'homme dans la
classification c'est là tout l'intérêt
d'une classification qui reflète
l'évolution un animal proche de notre
boîte sera aussi un animal avec qui nous
avons un très long passé en commun et
qui nous ressemble beaucoup ressembler
beaucoup une souris non mais non mais si
mais si regarde ce n'est pas parce que
nos lignées sont séparées depuis 70
millions d'années qu'il faut oublier que
nos destins philogénétiqu sont restés
liés pendant les 4 milliards 430
millions d'années qui ont précédé ça
laisse des traces et dans le cas de la
médecine cela fait que nos physiologies
sont tout à fait similaires et que nous
réagissons de façon comparable aux
médicaments c'est aussi pour cela qu'on
a longtemps pratiqué des tests sur les
singes même si c'est pas cool pour eux
la classification c'est aussi la réponse
à la question de l'existence d'une vie
extraterrestre prenons tout à fait au
hasard
lestardigrade tout ça parce qu'une
poignée de ces charmantes bestiol à
survqué une courte exposition au vide
spatial certains sont allés chercher
l'idée au perché que les tardigrades
seraiit des extraterrestres pourtant
tout de l'origine évolutive des
tardigrades se trouve dans leur
classification les tardigrades sont de
tout petits animaux vivant dans l'eau
douce et munie d'une cuticule articulée
la cuticule articulée est une innovation
évolutive qu'on retrouve chez les
arthropodes uniquement crab scorpion
insecte Daphni ainsi on a longtemps
pensé qu'ils étaient de très proches
parents des insectes avant que leur gène
ne montre qu'en fait ils se placent à
l'extérieur des arthropodes en tant que
groupe frères de ces derniers formant
avec eux et avec les onicophores la
famille des panarthropodes en aucun cas
je dis bien en aucun cas il n'a été
question dans ce débat sur la position
philogénétique des tardigrades d'en
faire des extraterrestres pourquoi et
bien tout simplement parce qu'un
extraterrestre n'aurait pas sa place
dans notre classification non pas qu'on
voudrait pas lui en faire une hein mais
simplement qu'il ne la trouverait pas
par définition un être vivant
extraterrestre aura connu une histoire
évolutive sans aucun équivalent avec
celle qui a eu lieu sur Terre ainsi il
ne partagerait aucune similitude avec
des espèces que l'on connaît il n'aurait
aucune structure morphologique ni aucun
gène comparable à ceux des espèces que
nous connaissons et qui nous permettrait
de le classer aurait-il même seulement
de l'ADN pour vous faire comprendre à
quel point un extraterrestre serait
différent de nous imaginez-vous en train
de communiquer avec un sainjint dauphin
bon c'est difficile hein maintenant
imaginez-vous en train de discuter non
pas avec un chien non pas avec une
souris pas avec une fourmi non mais avec
un arbre vous vous rendez compte
maintenant à quel point il est différent
de vous vous l'arbre et bien rendez-vous
bien compte qu'il ne s'agit même pas là
d'un extraterrestre un arbre c'est du
100 % terrestre de chez nous ainsi
contrairement au tardig grade à qui on a
aisément trouvé une boîte confortable au
côté des arthropodes dans la
classification du vivant un
extraterrestre lui tomberait
complètement à l'extérieur de nos boîtes
quelque part par ici tant d'applications
tant de possibilités j'ai envie de dire
à la cladistique que je t'aime que je
t'aime je
[Musique]
taime cette vidéo un peu spéciale a été
réalisée en soutien à la campagne de
crowdfunding pour une nouvelle
application éducative nommée cladistica
cladistica est un jeu pour iPhone et
iPad où l'on classe les espèces suivant
leur lien de parenté d'un simple geste
du doigt cladistica c'est un peu le
tinder de la philogénétique n'hésitez
pas à consulter les liens dans la
[Musique]
description